Uh uh, Chairman Cook is that. Now, many people say it is depressing
, and if you open it for the purpose of breaking words, you can call it soup.
Yes, Chee Lee Geum is the main character.
I use it for the first time today, so I have to spend 80 years again this year.
This is the first time I live. Grandma opened the door, then my father
gave me water, and I am running the business for the 3rd generation of the 3rd generation
now.
I can say that it is one of the few New Year's
Celebrations.
So Korean people like alcohol very much. In the
BRICS 10's and 80's, when I was growing up,
I did a lot of cassowary at work
.  You used a lot of water , and
now our chairman Kuk has a lot of sugar in the net dried in the rice ,
and the beggars in the beggars are abundant , so it continued the tak-s-boom that
day.  It is said to be helpful
Now our 5 refurbished old grandfathers are doing it again one by one
My reminiscence Cook My recipes are first to buy, and then the brisket intestines are in the
earth.
Goo Ha 2 is cooking half of the way it used to be
5 Now I am still eating one meal a day every day I think of my
hands as the most delicious food in the world.
I can. Whenever it's
hot, I eat while thinking of the old people.
Now I also have a thought that it would be good to continue teaching for two days like this until the next
time
[Music]